it's kind of like the monsters are on uh
Maple Street
that's the uh that's the breakfast Pixar
movie yes it's about Maple Street is
this syrup street right it's more like a
river but like uh or just a sticky Road
I guess yeah a really gross Road
those frogs are hopping in the lily pads
which are pancakes it's a yeah well it's
about a waffle man the waffle man he
comes syrup everywhere okay it's it's
definitely appropriate for kids to go to
a clip I actually
I remember that because somebody
actually it's really weird because
somebody sent me this a while ago
because they thought we were in it
because the the people with the waffle
man look like us
what what are you paying this editor by
the way
and we're back
don't really go in do they this is all a
gag right